the relationship between Hong Kong and
China is at its lowest for decades it
goes back hundreds of years but these
are the six moments you need to
understand to really get why it's become
such an important issue 1842
this is when Britain took control of
part of Hong Kong after the First Opium
War fast-forward five decades and China
gave him the rest of it but only for 99
years 1997 this is when that lease ran
out by that time China had been a
communist state for nearly 50 years and
Hong Kong remained democratic under UK
rule Britain handed control of Hong Kong
back to China who introduced the one
country two systems' rule basically this
meant the Hong Kong would be guaranteed
a high degree of autonomy from China
that would technically still be part of
the country Hong Kong kept a capitalist
economy freedom of speech and a free
press at least until 2047 2003 this was
the first major sign of discontent from
Hong Kong as pro China politicians tried
to introduce a bill that banned
criticizing China it triggered huge
protests with half a million people
taking to the streets the bill was
withdrawn a big win for anti China
protesters 2014 the umbrella movement
went on for months in Hong Kong it was
named that after demonstrators started
using umbrellas to protect themselves
from police teargas
protesters thought China's proposed
changes to Hong Kong's electoral system
were too restrictive thousands protested
and the controversial reforms were
shelved as a result
2019 five years later the biggest
demonstrations yet took place
this time they were triggered by a bill
would make it easier to send people to
mainland China to face trial but the
movement became much bigger and gave
people an opportunity to resist the
growing influence of China in Hong Kong
2047 for many 2047 is the most important
phase this is the year that China is
supposed to get full control of Hong
Kong ending the one country two systems'
rule Chinese leader Xi Jingping recently
changed the law meaning he could be
President for life how he deals at Hong
Kong is going to be a key part of his
presidency he is stuck between not
looking too heavy-handed to the West and
not looking too weak at home whatever
happens is already fraught relationship
isn't showing any signs of improving
[Music]